[Music]
hi I'm Conan O'Brien in a real gritty
urban setting you know producing a TV
show is very hard work that's why I need
your help I'm inviting everyone to
occupy Conan it's a contest where fans
will recreate a special episode of my
show
which will air on TBS that's right
Val you can enter for a chance to be on
Conan and when the all-new Volkswagen
Beetle converted here's how to do it
just go to team koco.com slash occupy
Conan 1st watch all the available clips
and pick which ones you want to occupy
next download the script grab a camera
and start shooting your reenactments be
creative you can use people puppets
animation or almost anything you'd like
for continuity we ask that your Conan
always has orange hair and a tie and
your Andy always has blond hair and a
tied consistency is key for more tips on
shooting a winning clip be sure to check
out team koco.com slash Occupy Conan FAQ
once you've shot and edited your
masterpiece head to team koco.com slash
occupied Conan to upload your clip the
deadline is 3 p.m.
January 4th all the entries selected by
our judges will be compiled into one
amazing groundbreaking episode of our
show that will air on TBS entitled of
your blood your help will make this the
greatest hour of television ever created
or just an hour of television we don't
care the bar is very low
[Music]